Is SEAC better to brew in herbal form or is the ready-made texture just as good?
I think the ready-made textures are just as good. So
You can say, oh, I'm going to brew it. It's fresher. It's really fresher at all. It's completely from a dried herb.
So, no, I think they're just as good. I think the weed, we don't even sell the dried herb form to brew.
Because I think it's just so much easier to just use it right out of the bottle and put it in the hot water and make a little tea out of it.
So
Either way, it's just important sleep.
The better the thing that is the danger of making your own teas of dried herbs is the longer you steep it, the more you're going to get out of it.
And the longer you steep it, you can get some things out of it that you don't want to get out of that herbal product either. So
If you use something that's prepared already, then you're getting a more
Even product throughout the use of the product.
So I think there's there can be benefits left.